attention mesdames et messieurs
[Musique]
à la télé les journaux tout le monde ah
le truc mais oui ce matin je suis allé
au pressing mais attends mais tout le
monde en parle
en ligne là
tout le monde en parle
chers amis chers ennemis bonsoir
bienvenue sur le plateau de Tout le
monde en parle vous connaissez le
principe tout le monde en parle alors
tout le monde en parle très bien vous
connaissez l'équipe voici linda Hardy
oh là là c'est chaud aujourd'hui
celle qui avec une pièce au splendide la
saison dernière s'est révélé être une
grande actrice que l'on compare
désormais à Jacqueline Maillan
j'accueille Michel Bernier
bonsoir
donc la pièce s'appelle le démon de midi
ensemble souvent alors oui donc c'est le
démon de midi au Splendid c'est un gros
gros succès et là vous êtes en tournée
Lyon Dijon Bourg-lès-Valence pour la bon
je sais plus quoi enfin bref la France
jusqu'au mois d'avril voilà
mise à part Michel Bernier nous recevons
ce soir Renaud Muselier
Laurent Bourgnon
Lio
et Marc Lavoine
[Musique]
alors vous savez que tout le monde en
parle n'est diffusé que trois fois par
mois franchement on se demande
alors donc la semaine dernière il y
avait pas de tout le monde en parle donc
le best of que je vais vous montrer
maintenant c'est celui de la semaine
d'avance et donc le zapping de
l'émission numéro 3 et ça s'appelle tout
le monde en a parlé magnéto Serge s'il
vous plaît
est-ce que vous trouvez est-ce que vous
trouvez ça bien de mentir ouais j'adore
c'est génial
bon tu essayes de voir si j'ai pas une
moumoute non c'est ça toute façon
mademoiselle j'ai un complément
capillaire uniquement là alors c'est
pour ça je te demanderai de toucher
uniquement cette partie là je te
remercie quelles sont les armes de
séduction que vous déployez consciemment
le regard
moi aussi
madame charade faites quelque chose
c'est la tranquille donc
est-ce que tu serais choqué si je
sortais avec ta fille
[Applaudissements]
donc voilà quoi oui l'histoire donc
c'est l'homme qui quitte sa femme pour
une plus jeune c'est vrai pour une plus
vieille Sardou
effectivement il y a une phrase qui
résume tout à fait le démon de midi
c'est toi tu la femme de ma vie mais
elle s'est autre chose c'est une fée
voilà
mais elles ont 25 ans donc c'est
terrible elle a fait en fait s'appelle
la fée [ __ ] oui je trouve que ça lui
va plutôt bien
parce que généralement on est assez peu
indulgent avec les jeunes filles quoi
c'est vrai mais c'est vrai que les
hommes aujourd'hui très régulièrement
des hommes quittent une femme de leur
âge ou qu'ils ont épousé avant de
devenir réussir une femme qui est restée
avec eux dans l'ombre pour que ces
hommes finissent par réussir
professionnellement puis quand ça va il
se dit celle-là ça fait déjà 10 ans ou
15 ans que je lui raconte mes trucs et
qu'elle m'énerve parce qu'elle me
connaît par cœur donc je vais raconter
mon histoire à une plus jeune qui
évidemment est complètement Baba et qui
dans 10 ans sera plaqué de toute façon
je leur signal il y a pas aussi le le
fait que les pouces parfois se laisse un
peu aller une fois qu'elle est casée
aussi le cacher les hommes mais c'est
vrai que les ménages
non mais c'est vrai
on peut se dire que pour moi on peut se
dire que le laisser aller dans un couple
et commun généralement parce qu'au bout
de quelques années c'est vrai que bon on
fait moins attention les uns aux autres
quoi généralement plus attaché au fusils
que les femmes
il avait des maîtresses mais on restait
en famille maintenant
enfin il faut des fois un peu les
pousser parce qu'il aimerait bien avoir
le beurre l'argent du beurre de la
première la nouvelle c'est pas drôle non
plus pour la nouvelle parce que la
nouvelle elle a quand même elle a la
pension alimentaire à payer c'est-à-dire
qu'il faut quand même une partie de
l'argent du nouveau ménage qui sert à
rien je la plaindrai pas
de temps en temps ils ramènent les
gosses elle est obligée de se faire des
les gosses avec apprendre un livre
d'accord
Michel le pardonne rien moi j'ai essayé
de me faire un peu l'avocat du diable il
y a rien à faire il y a des mecs tout
seul il y en a plein les petites
annonces il y a des mecs déjà divorcés
en plus pourquoi aller en chercher un
utiliser un ménage c'est
idiotes
serrer les dents
elle rage elle a envie de se venger mais
c'est très difficile de se venger il y a
qu'au cinéma quand on y arrive et puis
après elle se dit bon allez je vais
reprendre du poil de la bête quand même
et puis je vais je vais aussi faire
comme lui que je vais prendre des amants
bon alors le problème c'est où les
trouver quoi parce que c'est un petit
peu curieux cette histoire on parle que
de ça que d'amour et de se retrouver et
tout mais personne ne se retrouve il y a
beaucoup de gens seuls
en plus comment tu vas faire vous avez
plus envie de revivre avec un homme tout
de suite moi personnellement tout va
bien
je vis avec l'équipe de France de mais
dites-moi quand vous dites que
l'ancienne elle doit serrer les dents et
sourire essayer de serrer les dents et
de sourire pour voir
une grosse surprise parce que c'est vrai
que c'est pas un one man show faut dire
aux gens c'est pas des sketchs les uns
après les autres c'est une vraie pièce
c'est une pièce où vous êtes seul sur
scène mais ça n'est pas un one woman
show je dirais pour vexer personne et on
vous avez vu sur scène avec les avec les
filles mais là vous êtes là la première
fois seul et comme je le disais on
découvre vraiment tout le monde l'a dit
une actrice plutôt que la rigolote de
service qu'on avait l'habitude de voir
depuis le petit théâtre de Bouvard puis
dans d'autres émissions et chez Arthur
et le bonheur est permanent de cette
pièce elle est l'aiguille est tout le
temps dans le rouge quoi c'est on rigole
du début à la fin donc je le dis j'ai
pas fait fortune
quand je dis quelque chose comme ça
j'imagine que vous me croyez hein bon
vous croyez non bon alors et puis le
théâtre ça vous branche c'est mes
premières amours je pense que c'est
l'endroit où je suis plus heureuse c'est
c'est sur scène quoi c'est il se passe
un truc entre moi et le public et
magique
à la fin bah oui j'ai pratiquement joué
un an entre le palais des glaces et le
Splendid et voilà et là c'est reparti
pour 6 mois de tournée et j'espère
revenir à Paris après la volontiers donc
ça s'appelle on va en reparler toute
façon parce qu'on va beaucoup parler des
hommes des femmes ce soir tout ça là
tout ce qui nous intéresse vraiment en
fait
c'est quand même l'amour moi j'ai 25 ans
aujourd'hui donc je suis un peu bêta
non ça dépend
pas en fait
même si je ne m'attaque pas aux hommes
mariés mais est-ce que vous pensez que
par exemple quand j'aurai 40 ans enfin
quand les la nouvelle génération aura 40
ans ou 45 ans vous pensez qu'on subira
les mêmes désillusions
alors nous ce qui va se passer à mon
avis c'est que nous les femmes on va de
plus en plus vous
plaquera les cinq bosses tout tout pour
illustrer nos propos je vous propose
qu'on regarde un extrait du spectacle
donc le démon de midi de Michel Bernier
magnéto Serge s'il vous plaît
toutes les bonnes femmes de moins de 30
ans
[Musique]
parce qu'elles ont tous les gens et
pourquoi tu me direz-vous ben parce
qu'elle ne se laisse à plus elle le sait
que ça va être facile que le mâle
bagousait le rire gauche et la peau
idéale que vous disant c'est la même
couette à partager le même verre pour
les brosses à dents il a envie
d'entendre de la bouche et les coller
d'une pouf qui débrouille intelligent
quelle est la taille en brisément
sécurisant et que bien sûr il est le
premier homme à la rendre heureuse
raffante avec Al Pacino matinée
car son anniversaire on a fait un
karaoké qui l'a chanté sur ses Jérôme
les démons de midi le démon de midi donc
Michel Bernier marie-pascal osterix
d'après la BD je l'ai dit austérites
d'après la BD de Florence sesta qui
s'appelait pareil d'ailleurs
le changement j'adore c'est vrai
bon alors maintenant on va faire chaque
semaine comme ça j'invente un peu des
nouvelles interviews alors là je vous ai
réservé une interview assez c'est
l'interview à l'envers
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors est-ce qu'on peut baisser un petit
peu la lumière s'il vous plaît donc
l'interview à l'envers c'est très très
simple
je vous donne la réponse et vous me
donnez la question
alors
allons-y je vous donne un nom comme ça
vous allez me dire la question qui
aurait pu nous y amener Arthur
faites attention à ce que vous dites bon
alors je vais la faire gentil
quelle est l'animateur qui m'appelle
moumoune en il vous appelle Momo
[Rires]
quelle est l'animateur qui a la même
voix qui le coq
sur un rocher qui est l'émetteur qui est
sur un rocher maintenant et
Gildas c'est celui qui trouve toujours
un petit boulot au canal
l'animatrice dont j'aimerais avoir la
permanente
et Laurent Bignolas
alors lui je l'aime beaucoup oui
jusqu'à la fin de l'émission ah merci on
vous garde je vais accueillir maintenant
un homme politique que j'ai découvert un
jour en rentrant chez moi sur LCI moi je
mets beaucoup LCI parce que
ça me donne l'heure surtout le CAC 40 il
y a des réveils maintenant c'est en
vente libre c'est important d'avoir le
CAC 40 donc je l'ai vu sur cet homme
politique hein et j'ai dit les
formidable j'ai dit à Catherine Barma
est-ce qu'on pourrait pas l'inviter
alors on l'a invité il est là je connais
pas plus que ça vous non plus il
s'appelle Renaud Muselier
bonsoir
vous pouvez embrasser Linda c'est
compris dans le c'est compris dans le
circuit touristique
en plus pour une fois il y a un homme
politique jeune
merci je suis contente de voir vous êtes
très beau
ouais ouais il va essayer de d'avoir un
électorat féminin ça peut servir donc
bon on va brosser un petit peu votre
portrait vous avez 40 ans vous êtes
marié quatre enfants
médecins spécialisé dans les
traumatismes crâniens ce qui est parfait
après le score du RPR aux européennes et
vous êtes spécialisé dans les réveils
des comateux aussi ce qui est tout à
fait bien aussi pour le RPR parce qu'on
peut pas dire que le parti se porte très
bien
d'être d'accord ou pas d'accord non
c'est ma formation médicale après pour
le RPR c'est vrai qu'on a pris un coup
sur la tête aux européennes c'est clair
donc si on peut se servir de mon
expérience médicale pour refaire marcher
notre fonctionnement
des Bouches-du-Rhône premier adjoint ma
mère de Marseille monsieur Godin le 26
juin électrochoc vous décidez de vous
présenter à la Candy enfin la présidente
donnez votre candidature à la présidente
est-ce que Chirac était au courant non
vous avez fait ça sans l'accord de
Monsieur Jacques Chirac oui
la réalité
bien avec lui j'ai un grand respect pour
lui je l'ai toujours soutenu c'était le
président de mouvement politique c'est
le président de la République
aujourd'hui mais comme vous l'avez dit
j'ai 40 ans je suis marié j'ai 4 enfants
et vous fumez
normal j'ai pas besoin de demander à
maman l'autorisation de sortir le soir
pour mon mouvement politique alors vous
avez été le premier c'est vrai que le 26
juin vous étiez le seul à vouloir être
président du RPR puis depuis il y a eu
quand même un certain nombre de gens il
y a de le voir il y a Fillon il y a alio
Marie elle devait de gens mais vous êtes
persuadé qu'à la fin vous serez trois
Fillon de le voir et vous non je pense
que c'est la femme qui saute oui c'est
la fête
n'est pas du tout il y a des garçons
sont pas vraisemblablement d'après les
dernières informations là je pensais pas
qu'on aurait tous les signatures
ressemble à un moment
c'est signature finalement je sais pas
encore mais apparemment il est en train
de les avoir il est à 1850 donc il
devrait pouvoir passer là-bas bon alors
Renault vous voilà présenté maintenant
ce qu'on peut dire c'est que vous n'êtes
pas aidé par le RPR
ils ont dit le 26 juin quand vous êtes
déclaré ils ont dit il s'est tiré une
balle dans le pied pas très sympa quand
même je continue à courir
c'est sympa les rapports au sein des
artères
toutes les campagnes qui sont faites
pour qu'on vote et derrière vous arrivez
et c'est fini quoi
quand même le pire c'est Beyrout qui
fait le mariole il a fait 9 %. alors je
suis un vilain petit canard la machine
nationale du RP est contre moi ça c'est
ce que vous avez déclaré et alors ils
vous font des coups tordu quand même
parce que c'est ça vous avez reçu une
lettre de pendreau qui s'occupe de la
campagne de de le voir chez vous ça veut
dire qu'ils ont piqué le fichier du RP
et vous vous l'avez pas le fichier du RP
bah oui il a dû m'écrire parce qu'il
pensait qu'il pouvait peut-être me
convaincre à ses idées
ça vous énerve pas ça
sont tout ça ce sont des vieilles
méthodes tout ça faut le secouer faut
mettre un peu d'oxygène il faut
dépoussiérer tout ça donc quand vous
avez vos entreprenez une démarche comme
la mienne qui est une démarche qui est
de dire bien maintenant il faut qu'il y
ait un débat politique internet
maintenant il faut qu'il y a plusieurs
candidats il faut que tout le monde
s'exprime et puis on verra bien ils sont
les militants qui décident donc
forcément ceux qui ont les habitudes du
passé
pour moi c'est pas pareil mais vous
savez bien commencer il y a tout on dit
voilà ça va être la démocratie tout le
monde va vouloir pouvoir se présenter
que au bout d'un moment c'est switchira
qui est quoi non mais alors c'est pas
forcément gênant si avant les gens ont
pu s'exprimer présenter des choses
différentes s'exprimer voter tous
ensemble ce qui n'a jamais été le cas
tout le monde s'exprime à 90% quand même
pas le même méthode démocratie enfin
c'est pas tout à fait la même chose
c'est pas le même genre le pays et de
toute façon l'obligation de faire une
révolution culturelle dans ton mouvement
politique si on le fait pas
et bien on continuera à voir des
défaites électorales des gens qui ne
vont plus voter des déceptions et des
gens nous on est triste
on va essayer de modifier les choses
dites-moi avant de venir au spectacle
parce que c'est vendredi je vais faire
une parenthèse Renault à vendre revenir
sur nos affaires du RPR
vous avez déclaré de toute façon j'aime
pas Paris donc c'est vrai que vous
n'êtes pas enfin vous la jouer un peu
province que c'est un peu votre
positionnement les élites parisiennes le
microcom parisien vous mettez un petit
peu en dehors oui mais c'est vrai que
nous marseillais on n'est pas
fondamentalement en phase avec les
Parisiens on n'est pas en phase avec le
poids centrale on a toujours été en
porte-à-faux on n'est pas on n'est pas
copain que ce soit dans le foot toute
façon dans le foot surtout en politique
ça soit avec les nains que ça soit avec
les les castes avec les élites
ceci étant à Marseille
en 94 ici on m'aime pas mais en 94
c'était fracturé la mâchoire et ouvrir
le crâne par des dockers qui
manifestaient
en 80 2014
à Marseille en 96 vous êtes sur
l'autoroute avec votre voiture de
fonction il y a une roue qui se détache
bizarre surtout quand la femme les
enfants dans la voiture ça fait mal
ça fait pas ça fait ça fait pas plaisir
la famille
en 97 il y a 2 ans donc trouver une pile
dans votre moteur qui qui devait
chauffer [ __ ] le feu au moteur etc
c'est dangereux quand même c'est c'est
difficile de pouvoir toujours s'exprimer
avec ses convictions et son caractère
quoi vous êtes attaqué au bandit là-bas
non non rassurez-moi vous êtes inquiétez
pas la mafia au moins je dis ce que je
pense forcément ça gêne bien alors
reviens sur les RPA seule question moi
j'ai envie de vous poser c'est pourquoi
il y a six candidats et pourquoi se
donner autant de mal pour être le patron
d'un parti aussi pourri non mais non
mais franchement
on t'aime bien mais là tu exagéré
de temps en temps quand je dis des trucs
un peu merci donc j'aime mon mouvement
politique il est en difficulté je pense
que nous avons une autre pays gouvernée
par la gauche et mal gouverné je
voudrais qu'il soit que vous allez par
la droite ça passe par un appareil
politique aussi
il y a pas de réseau
par la droite
ceci étant vous savez très bien
l'homme qui se fait celui qui dit non
non pas du tout parce qu'il y a eu une
première qui a été faite avec des amis
de Jacques Chirac je le
voyouited donc j'avais un match de foot
moi que c'est
donc je suis allé
on a vu la con que c'était à Londres
alors vous avez dit je roule pour Chirac
comme je l'ai toujours fait Chirac je
l'aime alors c'est un truc qui me
surprend toujours avec les chiraciens
c'est que vous l'aimez c'est un peu
inquiétant c'est quand même si vous
l'aimez comme ça là parce que c'est un
homme bon c'est un homme de cœur un
homme de caractère c'est une tempérament
c'est l'homme fidèle et je pense que
dans la vie c'est
[Rires]
tous les contacts que j'ai eu avec lui
sont des contacts qui sont des contacts
privés à différents je dirais des autres
candidats en permanence eux disent j'ai
téléphoné j'ai eu la secrétaire la
secrétaire mardi qu'il fallait faire ça
en fait il a eu en général on sait même
pas qu'ils ont eu on sait même pas
qu'ils ont eu moi je dis rien j'ai le
ration que j'ai et je fais ce que j'ai à
faire comme ça on est tranquille il est
marrant non il est très sympa
franchement vous êtes alors maintenant
on va parler non on va parler du RP moi
sympa parce que je vais vous expliquer
ce que c'est le RPR parce que ou c'est
un parti de droite libérale européen et
à ce moment-là ça s'appelle l'UDF ou
alors c'est un parti national
républicain social et à ce moment-là ça
s'appelle le RPF alors expliquez-moi
dans les repères vous avez des gens
comme devait de gens qui sont des
libéraux donc on comprend pas pourquoi
ils sont pas à l'UDF et puis vous avez
des gens comme Pasqua qui a fait le RPF
parce que lui il voulait défendre un
côté plus social républicain national
donc vous vous êtes où là maintenant moi
je nulle part
c'est un parti qui est assez unique en
Europe d'ailleurs de parler l'histoire
de la France de part de par son histoire
alors il est très facile à définir pour
ceux qui parce que ça va que c'est bien
la démarche générale de Gaulle j'ai
voulu 25 ans
mais parce que c'est très facile à
défendre
difficulté pour nous parce que ceux qui
ont vécu la guerre savent ce que c'est
les enfants de la guerre ils savent ce
que c'est les autres ils savent pas ce
que c'est et pour eux c'est une c'est
une histoire très proche histoire
contemporaine c'est moins de 50 ans
et et ils ont pas tout à fait réalisé
que ça a été la démarche d'un grand
homme d'une force considérable issue de
tous les tempéraments politiques
d'ailleurs
c'est difficile notamment pour les
jeunes ça c'est qu'est-ce qui va vous
arriver si vous parlez trop si vous nous
embarquez dans les discussions moi je
suis ravi de discuter avec vous et je
vais avoir
c'est ça ou alors je vous mets
10 secondes
je refuse les secrétaire national lui a
fait pour les questions de sécurité sur
la sécurité vous êtes très plus dur que
la gauche la difficulté
donc si quelqu'un ici a de la drogue sur
lui
cachez-le
tolérance bon alors sur le 0 parce que
vous avez vous avez une des petits
gestes de la vie quotidienne en ce qui
concerne les agressions des petites des
tout ce qui rendent la vie tout
parfaitement désagréable pour tous nos
concitoyens et que si on pouvait avoir
un système qui nous permette d'avoir
immédiatement une sanction faite par
quand vous êtes pris parce que vous
n'êtes pas la ceinture vous pouvez payer
tout de suite votre amende vous pouvez
vous savez que vous avez vos points qui
sautent vous avez vous êtes pris tout de
suite et bien c'est exactement la même
chose en ce qui concerne tous les petits
gestes de délinquance qui nous
pourrissent la vie au quotidien mais
c'est c'est ça quelque part l'approche
de ma conception une société d'une vie
ça veut dire qu'il y a 77000 policiers
en permanence qui nous surveille
d'accord c'est ça
c'est pas du fricage c'est un respect de
la loi je voudrais pas vous faire passer
pour un pour un type de droite extrême
parce qu'en fait lui il s'est enlevé
votre candidat à Vitrolles en 96 pour
que la gauche soit républicain quand
même il a été en plus je suis le premier
avoir battu un conseil général
international faut le dire
circonscription le Front national
faisait au départ
44%. très bien en tous les cas vous
exprimez clairement la dernière chose
c'est sur les 35 heures alors là vous
avez dit un truc c'est assez venez nous
expliquer vous avez dit le partage du
temps de travail tel que le jeu Aubry
c'est le premier qui a fait ça c'est
Philippe Pétain à Vichy en 40
quand vous avez j'ai fait sortir toute
la tous les missiles à la semaine
nationale à gauche quand j'ai fait ce
texte j'ai fait une comparaison ils sont
tous partis comme on leur avait dit ça
j'ai comparé la présentation du texte de
loi sous Pétain donc un Vichy avec la
préparation avec le texte de loi de
Madame AUBRY article par arctique ce
sont les mêmes mots ce sont les mêmes
phrases c'est sûr que quand vous leur
dites ça leur faites pas plaisir et
quand vous comparez à ce moment-là le
texte de Madame AUBRY avec un texte de
Vichy forcément il faut socialiste c'est
particulièrement désagréable et quand
vous le faites en plus comme vous le
faites en plus à l'Assemblée nationale
mais forcément il se lève tous ils
sortent enfin c'est une réalité que je
leur ai rappelé les choses donc vous
êtes tout ça pour dire que vous êtes
contre les 35 heures c'est à dire qu'on
est dans une logique terrible parce que
nous là on est on sait pas bien faire ce
qui concerne la communication Aubry a
expliqué aux gens que de toute façon
on a des idées
elle a expliqué à l'ensemble de la
France que de toute façon on pouvait
dans la vie gagner autant voir peut-être
plus tout en travaillant moins c'est
beau ça qui est contre ça donc je ne
connais pas et moi je connais pas non
plus de gens qui sont susceptibles de
réussir de gagner le travail
en travaillant moins tout en gagnant
j'ai jamais vu quelqu'un
non c'est assez facile à comprendre ça
communique bien est-ce que ça communique
bien là oui c'est comme ça
alors maintenant on va vous connaître un
petit peu plus là on est resté au plan
politique maintenant on va faire une
interview un petit peu plus personnelle
pour vous connaître un petit peu mieux
jusqu'à le pire alors j'ai appelé ça
entretien d'embauche bougez pas
[Musique]
voilà la lumière merci le jingle le
carton c'est comme la télé alors
entretien d'embauche donc répondez-moi
franchement alors votre nom on le
connaît Muselier prénom Renault surnom
alors surnom vous appelez petit tour
petit
ours est vraiment un truc du Midi
et vous c'est quoi
super bon alors museau
taureau ascendant scorpion ça vous dit
quelque chose vous scorpion c'est sexuel
j'ai tous les deux sur les Scorpions moi
bon alors votre père pharmacien déporté
à des choses pourquoi résistance
résistance fait de résistance très bien
c'est Lui qui a créé la clinique que
vous dirigez aujourd'hui avec son
associé qui est Monsieur joggansi voilà
il a décidé quand vous aviez 29 ans
voilà
est-ce que c'est pas la mort prématurée
de votre père qui vous amène comme ça
toujours rechercher Chirac un autre papa
non non je crois que depuis que je suis
tout petit je peux pas m'empêcher
d'ouvrir ma gueule quoi
je dis ce que je pense
alors votre mère bon ma mère c'est ma
mère j'adore voilà alors votre
grand-père excusez-moi c'est le
grand-père c'est une star énorme
mais c'est la sœur de la reine d'Albanie
ah mais attends là j'y arrivais
alors est-ce que vous cherchez alors
vous êtes le cousin germain de l'écart
premier roi d'Albanie qui est le fils de
zog le roi des aigles et le mari de
Géraldine la reine d'Albanie qui est la
sœur de ma mère
aujourd'hui le Lesquin premier roi
d'Albanie il vit en Afrique du Sud il a
un peu impliqué l'histoire de trafic
d'armes non
parce que de toute façon c'est un homme
qui vit en exil et il a eu 6 ou 7
tentatives d'assassinat contre lui donc
il a quelques hommes contre les quatre
premiers c'est très joli son père
ça c'est bien tout seul à l'époque ils
devaient se donner des noms comme ça
non c'est impossible
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
bon alors votre grand-père votre
grand-père c'est l'amiral Muselier donc
il a créé les forces françaises navales
libres et alors quand on dit qu'il a
donné la croix de Lorraine à la France
ça veut dire quoi c'est lui qui a eu
l'idée du symbole c'est à dire mon
grand-père était sa mère était
Marseillaise et son père était Laurent
et donc étant en Angleterre il dirigé
avec de enfin de Gaulle les forces
aériennes et les forces navales
aériennes navales et aériennes
françaises libres et pour faire la
différence entre la France libre et la
France occupée il a eu l'idée de la
croix de Lorraine qu'il avait imprimé
sur ses bateaux et sur ses avions dans
le blanc pour faire la différence par
rapport à la croix nazie d'accord
c'est devenu le symbole de la France
voilà l'amiral Muselier
alors votre taille 1m83 votre poids
76 kg pas mal
suivant mes interlocuteurs j'ai besoin
de Cannes la religion chrétienne
chrétiens alors Lévis maintenant vous
fumez quoi fumer des pétards non
Thierry il va vous dire oui ça
communique bien
la farine je fume pas de pétard je fume
pas de cigarette je fais plutôt du sport
et je bois j'adore le vin et j'aime la
vie bon bah écoutez très bien
donc je me suis marié en
mais je la connaissais depuis
pratiquement une dizaine d'années avant
bon bah donc ça va pas tarder je vais
arriver
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voilà vous êtes prêté aux questions
maintenant vous connaissez un petit peu
mieux Linda alors on sait que en ce
moment on parle beaucoup du Viagra et
donc moi je voudrais savoir si en tant
que médecin vous avez testé le Viagra
j'ai les prescrit
je suis en politique je l'ai prescrit
j'ai voulu l'essayer mais ma femme
l'interdit
les femmes en prennent on me l'a jamais
demandé donc
féminin on commence à en parler et cette
histoire de cette d'anglaise ça peut
poser un centre de difficultés
et donc médecin une jeune anglaise de 25
ans comme moi j'avais pas fait le
rapproche
donc à tester le Viagra masculin et ça
lui a permis d'avoir 9 orgasmes dans
deux heures
en plus
c'était
la semaine dernière
avec le même homme oui avec le même
d'accord
j'arrive dans la trancheuse
mesdames messieurs maintenant
j'accueille quelqu'un qui depuis 15 ans
additionne les tubes et puis aujourd'hui
on s'aperçoit que tout ça a été que des
bonnes chansons et ça finit par faire un
répertoire de qualité j'accueille Marc
Lavoine
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous connaissez cette chanson alors
il va la chanter
cette chanson ça tourne bien là
tournesol Caracol machin c'est optimiste
c'est sympa donc il va la chanter c'est
pour ça
c'est pas mal
c'est joli
une cagole à Marseille c'est une [ __ ]
c'est la femme de cake c'est la femme du
qu'axela quand elle joue à Marseille ça
sera la fête voilà bon alors septième
ciel 7e album 12 titres vous avez
composé 6 ça c'est nouveau avant vous
êtes tout le temps les paroles sur vos
albums il rare que vous écriviez les
musiques
il les faisait mieux que j'imaginais
pouvoir les faire moi-même voilà et puis
là la tournesol la musique c'est vous
par exemple pas mal je l'ai composé
des chansons et puis on les termine avec
quelqu'un sinon je vais ça valorise pas
mon travail avec quelqu'un qui est fort
dans la musique déjà ça valorise le
travail donc ça nous engage à continuer
alors maintenant on va vous faire une
petite vous aurez un blind test à la fin
de l'émission merci Thierry vous nous
chanterez les tournesols ça nous fera
plaisir et là on va faire une petite
interview story donc sur vous
ne bouge pas
[Applaudissements]
voilà
on peut essayer de faire des fonds
vous avez passé votre enfance à Wissous
votre père il y a des Marseillais qui
bavardent la basse ça m'étonne pas c'est
j'en suis sûr dès qu'il y a tu mets
trois marseillais ensemble c'était mon
copain dès que tu mets trois marques ils
sont marrants
ces gens là depuis le début ils rigolent
voilà formidable et pas belle la vie
voilà mais ça me manque ça alors votre
père Marc Lavoine votre père était fan
de jazz il voulait être saxophoniste
mais malheureusement il s'est retrouvé
au Tripostal à
vaugirardiste voilà il était très à
gauche très à gauche très à gauche
communiste syndical vendez lui ma
dimanche
et tout ça et il a dit mon grand truc
pour échapper aux propos politisés
syndicalise de mon père qui m'ont vite
et quoique voilà c'était parti
non et que non c'est pas les pieds
mobylette avec des copains il plantait
des temps mais c'est
au premier degré et il tournait des
spectacles en plein air avec des Super 8
voilà donc c'est vrai quand même c'est
non mais c'est intéressant c'est à dire
que vous qui avez été élevé donc par un
père de de toute ultra gauche mais très
à gauche un moment le discours vous a
non c'est pas lui c'est pas son discours
à lui c'est simplement que moi j'aime
pas trop les chapelle j'étais élevé dans
mon père était athée moi je croyant je
trouve que chacun doit trouver ça sa
nature ça vraie raison de vivre
non je crois pas non non parce que dans
tous les milieux je crois que les les
gens ont enfin ceux qui aiment leurs
enfants et ceux qui les leur laissent le
choix des des choses et ça c'est
important de ce qui est bien dans votre
histoire c'est que finalement on fait
toujours enfin souvent on fait on
accompli un petit peu le destin que nos
parents auraient voulu avoir on fait
souvent ce que alors vous votre père
donc il est fan de jazz saxophoniste il
se retrouve au triposté à la Vaugirard
évidemment c'était pas le rêve de sa vie
votre mère qui veut être pianiste
surtout des kilos et vous finalement
vous avez réussi un peu pour eux d'une
certaine façon oui mais quand même
toujours une culpabilité là-dessus un
peu de
comme le communisme est un échec il y a
une sorte de d'un coup de de d'avoir du
succès quand on vient d'un milieu
communiste on garde un petit truc de
culpabilité envers les autres on n'a pas
j'ai pas tellement envie de j'aime pas
trop le brio tout ce qui se voit tout ce
qui se montre tout ce qui est parce que
je trouve que c'est une agression vers
les autres c'est un beau discours de
tolérance et puis en plus il a une voix
tellement
je se passe sur après dans un jour vous
partez pour de bons vous allez à Lyon
faire du hard rock tout ça vous allez
tout le monde connaît l'histoire vous
êtes coursier et ensuite à l'Olympia il
est placeur il est ouvert et évidemment
c'était le supplice de Tantale pour lui
parce que il voulait être star puis tout
le temps il a amené les gens dans les
stars
j'ai vu la lumière
[Rires]
et donc un jour Patricia Coquatrix donc
vous présente Florence Aboulker qui vous
présente son fils Fabrice Aboulker et
vous commencez à faire toutes ces
chansons alors je vais les faire écouter
parce que moi je trouve formidable tout
à l'heure elles sont pas toutes je dis
simplement c'est un choix personnel mais
avec toi
[Musique]
elle a le regard
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non elle est jolie celle-là
j'avais 17 ans
et tout ça quand on dit sept ans on
écrit un truc comme ça ça va quand on a
37 ans
allez laisse-le aller
c'est génial
ça c'est magnifique
ça c'est très vieux
elle vous adore
quand vous étiez petit non mais d'accord
[Musique]
alors les prénoms enfin les surnoms ont
changé jusqu'au dernier qu'on m'a donné
c'est Ravalec qui me l'a donné sur le
tournage quand il de laracal un cahier
marcoïc de dire que le film s'y prêtait
vous étiez le mari de Claire Nebout dans
le film mais c'était des échangistes qui
allaient au Cap d'Agde il faut voir il
faut avoir vu ce film ça existe
[Rires]
il a commencé par grandir par les
oreilles sérieusement vous trouvez beau
sérieusement Thierry je me pose pas la
question et puis je m'en fous un peu
parce que nous on retrouve tous
vachement beau et je suis ravi
on me dit aussi tout le monde vous
trouve très beau et il y a du boulot
là il y a du France 2 et tout il y a de
la
hypnose
vous dites-moi physique je le trouve
plutôt dur vous avez déclaré à mon
physique je trouve plutôt dur genre nazi
coupé au couteau parce que comme je suis
très impressionné quand je vais à la
télévision de ça pour moi j'ai
l'impression de rentrer dans une
institution parce que je l'aime beaucoup
la télévision donc il y a des endroits
où j'ai tendance à me faire mais c'est
vrai que je suis plus beau d'une
certaine manière si on parle de de quand
je suis décontracté quand je suis en
confiance avec les gens c'est pour ça
que je reste par exemple
je crois que la beauté c'est donner
c'est donner pleinement aux choses et
puis de faire
avec avec la nature on va se faire
attends où elle est où ma chanson moi on
va se faire une petite image rose là
vous allez voir
cette série donc chez vous donnez vous
la main caressez-vous caressez-vous
tenez-vous la main non parce que c'est
un moment
la beauté sans quelqu'un ça ne sert à
rien quoi alors justement en 92 ou là
vous avez dit ouais en parlant du couple
le côté on ne fait plus qu'un moi ça me
gonfle en 93 il a déclaré jamais je ne
dirai à une femme on est ensemble pour
la vie car j'en sais rien alors est-ce
que Sarah penetowski vous a fait changer
d'avis ou est-ce que quand même vous
pensez toujours ça non je pense pas ça
du tout vous avez changé d'avis je suis
amoureux de la femme que j'aime donc si
tu veux ça ça règle tout le problème
c'est pas Michel qui sont plaindre
le démon de midi
c'est parce que je préfère
vous allez faire des vous allez faire
des malheurs
[Applaudissements]
la sexualité en dehors de l'amour ne
m'intéresse pas trop c'est ce que je
veux dire donc j'ai jamais quelqu'un de
peureux je suis pas du tout
sexualité pourquoi pas il préférait
l'amour sans sexualité que la sexualité
ça peut m'arriver alors on se demande
lequel le plus
cher
et c'est parti
est-ce que ça vous fait pas un choc vous
fils de militant communiste d'épouser la
dernière descendante des rois de Pologne
est-ce que c'est pas est-ce qu'au niveau
du je sais pas quand vous avez amené
chez vous parce que le switch s'est bien
passé le moment où j'ai viré le écoute
non pas la première fois mais quand ils
sont allés chez les parents de l'un et
l'autre ce genre de question me déroute
surtout venant de vous parce que je sais
que vous êtes quelqu'un d'extrêmement
brillant et je vous aime beaucoup et
c'est vrai que la question je sais
qu'elle vient pas de vous c'est une
question qui traîne que vous reprenez et
que vous me posez mais vous ne pensez
pas ça par exemple on sait pas qu'un mec
qui vient de mieux communiste
donc ça m'étonne beaucoup encore à la
comme ça au seuil au seuil je me vois
pas épouser mon Seigneur Gaillot non
plus voilà par exemple il est pas sur le
marché
ça veut dire simplement qu'on refuse
d'être surpris par la vie dernière
question on marque Lavoine ce mariage à
Marrakech voulait trouver un peu médias
trop médiatisé non
ça va pas attirer c'est comme cette
question là c'est pas une idée à vous
c'est pas une idée à moi non c'est à
dire que si enfin je veux pas non plus
ne pas assumer les choses c'est à moi de
c'est moi qui l'ai fait donc
les journalistes sur le dos autant
essayer de les gérer quoi il sait tout
lui c'est un enfer c'est que
oui mais en revanche en revanche
j'aime beaucoup l'attacher de prince qui
travaillait pour moi à l'époque et je
n'en veux pas du tout je pense qu'il a
raisonné d'une manière extrêmement
sincère c'était à moi de penser que
finalement c'est vrai les attachés de
presse vit plus avec la presse qu'avec
les artistes d'une certaine manière et
j'aurais dû avoir une analyse c'est pas
très grave comme quoi parfois faut
savoir dire non il faut savoir
communiquer autour d'une langue que l'on
dit ça c'est bien
il est très sympathique lumière s'il
vous plaît
[Musique]
merci merci
je suis heureux de vous voir comme ça
sur un plateau de télévision franchement
moi je suis très heureux pour vous
Thierry vous restez avec nous
oui c'est vrai ouvrir
là qui sont assez étonnantes donc
j'accueille maintenant trois des auteurs
ou des autrices et nous dirons comment
il faut dire en tous les cas pas des
auteurs de la rentrée donc j'accueille
Isabelle Alonso Karine Bernfeld et petit
escale
bonjour
Isabelle
Isabelle Alonso Karine bernstel et
Clotilde escale voilà bon alors on va
commencer avec vous Isabelle alors votre
livre voilà je le montre à la caméra
voilà
ça s'appelle tous les hommes sont égaux
même les femmes
les publier et encore je me retiens
ensuite j'ai été remarqué parce que ça
s'est plutôt bien vendu vous êtes parti
aux Grosses Têtes ensuite vous êtes
partis chez notre ami Laurent Ruquet
pour moi
non pourquoi
ah bah parce que tout à l'heure je me
suis définie par rapport à Michel
bon alors donc chez Lafont tous les
hommes sont égaux même les femmes alors
de quoi ça parle parce que maintenant je
sais pas qu'on parlera d'une pièce d'un
machin tu sais de quoi ça parle c'est un
vibrant plaidoyer pour la mixité alors
pas seulement pour le partage
entre les hommes et les femmes du monde
traditionnellement d'évoluer aux hommes
c'est-à-dire la politique économie etc
mais aussi pour que les hommes viennent
dans le monde traditionnellement d'évolu
aux femmes à savoir le soin aux petits
enfants et et la couture et les travaux
ménagers en général
que par exemple les hommes donnent le
biberon passent l'aspirateur fasse les
courses et tout ça et ben oui c'est pas
possible
chérie ne fais pas les ménages j'arrive
j'arrive
c'est la mixité dans tous les domaines
de la vie est-ce que ça s'impose
au moins déjà en parler parce que on
impose depuis tellement longtemps
regardez même des mecs pas con dès qu'il
est question du féminisme ils viennent
il y a plein de mecs
je sais pas quoi
même les plus cultivés quand il parle du
féminisme ils viennent à l'alphabet oui
c'est vrai qu'il y a pas de culture il y
a pas de culture les mecs quand il
s'agit du féminisme ou des femmes en
général ils deviennent ils deviennent
analphabète
j'espère pas forcément le revolver mais
c'est un signe vous savez le revolver
c'est le phallus donc c'est le pouvoir
passer une bonne soirée tous ensemble
de parité dans la vie politique c'est
pas monsieur Muselier qui va être contre
je sens qu'il va me dire que j'ai raison
mais on peut aussi parler de parité dans
les cuisines les buanderies et les
crèches parce que s'il y a si les mecs
partagent pas ce genre de tâches là on y
arrivera jamais à la parité politique
donc voilà il faut parler de tout alors
vous vous êtes vous pensez non mais
sérieusement vous pensez que finalement
tout ce qu'on appelle la féminisation du
monde actuel on dit le monde se
féminisme par exemple vous vous dites
que c'est un bluff médiatique que c'est
pas mal on dit le monde se féminisme
attention les hommes sont angoissés
parce que le monde se féminisme aussi
moi je dis aussi les ovaires c'est comme
l'oxygène ça sera rifié avec l'altitude
c'est-à-dire que quand vous montez dans
les hiérarchies dans les dans les faites
pas cette tête
quand on monte dans les hiérarchies il y
a plus de femmes quoi et cette
féminisation du monde c'est pas parce
que les femmes sont devenues visibles
dans les médias par exemple sur ce
plateau il y a un homme et une femme
est-ce que vous êtes dans des positions
équivalentes pas du tout et on confond
la visibilité avec le pouvoir parce
qu'il y a beaucoup à dire mais là vous
écrivez
je ne me soucie guère d'être légal d'un
être à qui je ne reconnais aucune
supériorité donc on a toujours dit il
faut que les femmes se les égales des
hommes et vous dites aucune supériorité
à l'homme je vois pas pourquoi je
voudrais
ça aussi
la première aberration c'est de voir que
le numéro de sécu d'un homme commence
par un et celui d'une femme par un deux
c'est quoi ça ça met tout de suite dans
la bonne couleur
mais je ne la nie pas
et celui qui nous a apporté la
contraception le droit à l'avortement le
droit de vote etc la possibilité énorme
que auquel nous avons droit parce que
nous sommes des êtres humains à part
entière et les égales des hommes après
en les histoires de couches et de cours
etc je me dis de toute façon il y a il y
a un moment où il y en a un des deux qui
doit le faire et je vais dire si on se
met avec
j'ai envie de dire aux filles j'ai envie
de dire aux filles mais attends éduquer
vos mecs ou choisissez un mec bien un
mec sympa
c'est abruti qui font rien
le problème c'était quand il a fait les
courses pendant 6 mois après il se casse
maintenant
je voudrais pas ajouter une petite
touche de vécu mais alors tu rentres le
soir après le boulot tu vois tout le
monde est passé le mec attends je te
raconte l'histoire c'est tous les jours
et puis là tu dis au mec bon écoute j'en
ai un petit peu ras-le-bol je suis un
peu saturé les 10 derniers pressing
c'est moi les 10 derniers supermarchés
c'est moi les 10 derniers bains du petit
c'est moi et le mec te regarde il dit tu
comptes maintenant
tu aimes tu parles de ça pour avoir la
paix tu fais le boulot tu fermes ta
gueule et tu te tapes ta deuxième
journée
[Applaudissements]
que les nanas arrêtent je veux dire
peut-être bon moi ça y est c'est de la
faute des nanas je dis pas ça je dis
qu'il y a je veux dire je pense que il y
a un échange il y a un échange qui doit
être obligatoire aujourd'hui genre le
conflit on peut pas le on peut pas le
perpétrer tout le temps tout le temps je
pense que c'est important que
effectivement quand on a envie de se
battre on se bat qu'on se met une
gonzesse ou un mec
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir donc vous avez commencé en
posant nu dans les écoles de dessin oh
là là ça y est ça recommence
pas de même que je suis à la Sorbonne
mais ça il ne mentionne pas si on sait
que c'est intéressant
si vous étiez d'accord pour vous
déshabiller ça serait encore plus
vendeur mais comme vous êtes pas
d'accord
de la passivité
de quoi ça parle de quoi ça parle c'est
un journal intime à deux voix s'il vous
plaît les Marseillais excusez-moi Karine
c'est terrible
ah mais parce qu'il est pour la
tolérance zéro mais là apparemment pas
avec ses copains
de deux personnages une jeune fille
Stella qui a 16 ans un jeune homme
gallade qui a 21 ans l'idée de base de
ce bouquin c'est il y a quelques années
j'ai failli faire des gamins avec un
type un peu un peu enfin aussi avec moi
on va dire et je me suis imaginé ce que
ces enfants seraient devenus si on les
avait fait voilà donc c'est dans le pari
des années 2015 et c'était là et
galadade son nom écrit tous les deux
leur journal intime un sur l'ordinateur
Tendance Bi tombe amoureux d'une ado
lesbienne c'est pas mal c'est ça
un jeune adulte hétéro Tendance Bi tombe
amoureux d'une ado lesbienne assez l'an
2000 faut vous y faire
c'est demain important
c'est vraiment les personnages
singuliers ou vous trouvez que c'est le
reflet d'une société aujourd'hui qui est
complètement déboussolée parce qu'on a
l'impression que c'est un peu le
singulier du tout puisque déjà pour
écrire ce livre j'ai pris 10 ans de mon
propre journal intime donc
moi je trouve pas moi je trouve pas il y
a un côté non il y a un côté désespéré
mais en même temps il y a beaucoup
d'humour
ni homony Bee je suis sexuel c'est pas
mal ça c'est juste
que
voilà je supporte pas qu'on étiquette
les gens sont toujours
donc queer
on casse les gens il y a plus d'hommes
de femmes de [ __ ] de [ __ ] tout ça on
est tous pareils on est des êtres
humains on est des personnes et avec
chacun des moments où on peut être un
peu plus [ __ ] ou un peu plus hétéro voilà
qu'est-ce qu'on pense Muselier monsieur
vous avez compliqué quand même pas moi
dire que là je comprends qu'on peut être
passif un moment dominant un autre mais
pour autant il y a un mâle une femelle
pourquoi pourquoi on dit un mec qui se
fait prendre c'est un [ __ ] [ __ ] c'est une
insulte ok vous dites en général ils
sont mieux que les autres
forcément un peu moins mauvais que la
moyenne vous forcement puisque voilà
vous dites oui on a quand même les mâles
et les femelles je veux bien
vous pouvez couper toute la phrase en
fait j'ai pas dit de ton truc avant
l'évolution dans la vie sexuelle
par les femmes quoi aujourd'hui Renaud
aujourd'hui peut-être peut-être
les gens par leur pratique sexuelle
strictement aucun intérêt toutes les
pratiques sexuelles d'ailleurs
pénétrer être passif mais avec une femme
voilà ce serait déjà ça sera déjà
aujourd'hui
un député RPR qui aurait eu des petits
bracelets comme ça ça aurait été
méchamment
sur la plage cet été
bon vous avez dit l'hétérosexualité la
plus grande utopie du Mali donc ça
c'était là qu'il le dit c'est mon
personnage c'est pas moi ok
il est pas loin de vous si jamais un
proche à vous faire ça manque un peu de
distance par rapport on vous voit tout
de suite
pas du tout
si je m'étais pas soignée quoi c'était
vraiment ça quoi ma mère n'a rien d'une
anorexique bon alors il y a une phrase
que j'ai relevé c'est l'inconvénient
avec les mecs ça ça va être un beau
sujet de discussion pour nous ce soir
mes amis j'aimerais phrase énorme
l'inconvénient avec les mecs c'est que
dès que tu gémis un peu ils pensent que
tu as eu un orgasme
quand vous faites semblant non non non
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
c'était là dit que ça n'a aucun intérêt
de stimulé parce que en plus on fait
croire au mec que ça nous plaît alors
qu'en fait c'est nul donc elle dit
l'inverse elle dit franchement il vaut
mieux se taire comme ça il va se rendre
compte puis après il y a aussi cette
jeune que je me termine
elles sont bien les petites honteuses
maintenant là non les petites choses
dans l'hétérosexualité l'acte sexuel se
termine avec l'éjaculation donc l'homme
si la fille elle a pas eu son compte
qu'est-ce qu'elle fait bon bah c'était
là c'est ce qu'elle fait elle dit bon ça
te gêne que je me termine bon bah le mec
il le prend mal quoi
je suis tellement pas comme ça que je
comprends pas qu'il y a des mecs qui
laissent les filles se terminer toute
seule non mais c'est vrai
il y a personne ici qui a une enfance au
Maroc non personne
n'empêche
non c'est pas de la merde bon alors
beaucoup dès qu'il y a un mec de théâtre
qui a un en polonais moi je suis scotché
là et puis trois livres et le dernier
c'est Herbert Jouy chez calm and Lévy
alors je vais vous faire le même voilà
ça parle de quoi moi je le sais mais je
vous laisse le raconter ça parle du
désir d'un vieillard qui est satisfait
par une jeune femme
c'est pour ça que ça s'appelle Herbert
Jouy le vieux s'appelle Herbert
75 et avant de mourir il aimerait
connaître quand même la jouissance une
dernière fois parce que les vieillards
finalement leur univers rétrécit
énormément un moment donné je demande
s'ils vont arriver à marcher si vous
arrivez à boire à manger puis à la
jouissance et la jouissance dans ce cas
là c'est une élévation c'est la lumière
c'est pas sale c'est pas c'est pas
pornographique c'est la jouissance c'est
tout et ce vieil Herbert envie de jouir
et comme c'est un roman il y a une jeune
fille qui passe par là et puis
elle est tente elle est tendre en même
temps elle dit quand elle l'embrasse
elle dit c'était bien
il a les yeux globuleux un sourire
plutôt gentil
ce qui est bien c'est qu'il a l'air
propre bien sûr il a un peu goûté il
trompe sur ses jambes bah il y a 75 ans
le mec en même temps et alors ce qui est
rigolo avec lui
c'est ce que je voulais c'est dans une
société comme la nôtre c'est vrai qu'on
occupe beaucoup la vieillesse un moment
donné hop au placard et ce qui m'est
arrivé m'est arrivé dans ma vie d'aller
dans des maisons de retraite et de voir
ses vieux complètement livrés à
eux-mêmes attaché parce que ils avaient
un désir ils avaient un fantasme et puis
on les on leur remettait leur culotte et
puis voilà et on leur donnait des
calmants et je faisais très très
pathétique
quand j'entends ce genre de truc je
commence à flipper
[Applaudissements]
et donc j'ai repéré des vieux qui me
regardaient une drôle de façon passons
beaucoup de temps dans cette maison de
retraite je me suis j'ai commencé à
fantasmer et je me suis dit beurre doit
connaître la jouissance avant d'aller en
maison de retraite voilà mais vous vous
étiez déjà un peu prédestiné à écrire ce
genre de bouquin parce que Siri vous
avez couché avec le croque-mort qui est
venu chercher votre grand-mère dans le
livre dans le livre
pas du tout
je vous raconter tellement bien il y a
des détails que je ne peux pas donner
parce qu'on est sur France 2 c'est une
chaîne du service public
j'aimerais bien savoir
[Rires]
donc il peut pas assumer deux choses à
la fois à tantôt il bande ton dos il
veut me faire jouir
on se demande est-ce que c'est un ange
du ciel un envoyé du ciel qui est là
pour donner un peu de bonheur à ce
powerbère ou est-ce qu'au contraire s'il
n'èvera pas de gérontophile moi je le
prendrai plus comme un enfant
du ciel qui fait ça par compassion
peut-être après que dans sa
problématique elle préfère trouver
refuge auprès d'un vieillard et ne plus
subir le regard de la société comme
finalement ce vieillard est en dehors de
la société donc il peut y avoir ça il
s'amuse comme des enfants il se cache de
la société et font leur petites choses
avec légèreté parce qu'on dit que c'est
sale ou que c'est c'est pas honnêtement
il y a des trucs qui sont pas très
ragoutants dans le bouquin toujours des
poils qui traînent dans les baignoires
un peu tu sais quoi je veux dire
les vieux ont parfois la vue basse alors
vous avez une vraie compassion pour les
deux je vais garder votre numéro de
téléphone dans quelques années
Isabelle Alonso tous les hommes sont
égaux même les femmes voilà c'est chez
qui je vois pas là Robert Laffont très
bien ensuite Karim Benfeld apologie de
la passivité c'est chez qui Jean-Claude
latesse et vous donc herberge oui c'est
chez Kalman Levy et vous vous appelez
Clotilde escale merci beaucoup les
filles on vous a plu
[Applaudissements]
eh c'est des choses c'est gonzac
et alors elle c'est les vieux voilà
et elle là-bas
choisis bon alors j'accueille maintenant
mesdames messieurs quelqu'un qui le 17
octobre avec son frère Ivan va partir
pour la Transat Jacques Vabre donc sur
son trimaran Foncia qui s'appelait pris
magasin avant vous l'avez tous reconnu
bien sûr c'est Laurent Bourgnon
bonjour à tous
salut
le bateau
alors tout de suite j'en profite parce
que là
je me suis tenu à carreau
alors Laurent bognon donc la Transat
Jacques Vabre du Havre à Carthagena
alors c'est quoi le circuit là
dites-nous là qu'on voit parce qu'on
connaît pas bien géographie mais alors
on parle de du Havre
et ensuite on va donc on va virer la
Barbade
on remonte toutes les Antilles jusqu'à
Saint-Barthélémy on va au Nicaragua là
vous prenez la coque si vous la prenez à
Saint-Barthélemy oui enfin faut Colombie
et ensuite on va sur Carthagène
et nous en fait on a un petit peu plus
rapide ils nous font faire des petits
aiguilles un petit peu partout vous
partez le lendemain vous en plus on
parle le lendemain alors déjà donc en 97
vous avez gagné cette course hein avec
Yvan et cette année c'est Yvan qu'est-ce
qu'ils perd pourquoi ben parce que c'est
son partenaire Foncia et voilà c'est et
maintenant c'est lui qui va reprendre le
bateau jusqu'à la prochaine Route du
Rhum vous allez faire vos moi je suis en
train de construire un catamarante 38
mars le gros projet là alors vous avez
déclaré Laurent bornion pour moi faire
de la télé c'est aussi contraignant que
brosser la coque de mon bateau
il faut le faire je le fais mais qu'on
me demande pas en plus de sourire et là
vous souriez et là vous seriez ben non
c'est vrai qu'on est avant tout notre
passion c'est naviguer c'est de se faire
plaisir sur sur l'eau et mais bon cela
dit on change un petit peu notre fusil
d'épaule parce qu'on rencontre des gens
formidables mais non mais vous avez dit
la première fois que j'étais au théâtre
c'est pour aller voir Michel vous allez
non mais vraiment on se marre du début à
la fin vu l'extrait que j'ai vu tout à
l'heure ma plus
beaucoup voilà moi je vous connaissais
pas très bien et moi non plus et donc
j'ai appris votre vie enfin j'ai lu
votre vie et c'est vrai enfin tout le
monde doit la connaître j'imagine c'est
une star énorme mais vos parents étaient
boulangers dans le Jura Suisse à La
Chaux-de-Fonds jusque là rien de voilà
et puis alors quand vous
êtes toujours des frontières quand vous
avez quatre ans vos parents lisent le
vagabond des mers du sud de Bertrand
Moitessier et là ils vendent la
boulangerie ça c'est énorme ils vendent
la boulangerie ils achètent un voilier
de 12 mètres le père bornion fait un
stage de de trois semaines au glaisant
donc on peut pas dire que c'est vraiment
et qu'est-ce qui fait vous il traverse
l'Atlantique c'est-à-dire c'est vrai
tout à fait ils étaient passionnés en
fait au départ par l'aventure les
voyages les rencontres et connaissait
absolument rien en bateau et voilà en
deux stages de 15 jours ils ont ils ont
mis les voiles direct on est parti en
famille c'est incroyable
alors votre mère après se retrouve
enceinte de votre frère Ivan là il
rentre à Pornic ils achètent un café
mais quand ils 9 ans et vous 13 ans tour
du monde à la voile 36 mois en fait
l'objectif au départ c'était de voyager
donc finalement quand on arrive en
Polynésie le moyen le plus court pour
rentrer c'est de faire le tour puis
voilà quoi donc on s'est baladé pendant
incroyable ça très jeune quoi déjà de 13
ans vous étiez équipier quoi vous teniez
votre place sur le sur le bateau en fait
ce que dit votre père en tous les cas
ouais obligé ouais alors là vous avez
passé 7 mois au marquise d'aller à
l'école en planche à voile quand même ah
il a une enfance
voilà et alors en 86 là je raconte un
peu parce qu'il y a quand même encore
des gens qui vous connaissent pas en 86
et 20 ans et là vous faites l'Atlantique
en hobby 4
il faut savoir c'est un tout petit
bateau
on a 20 ans on est plein d'énergie et
c'est vrai qu'on a envie de se faire
plaisir qu'on va on est à recherche de à
la recherche de sensations et c'est vrai
que là on s'était fait 22 jours de piste
noire sans prendre de remontante et
c'était un plaisir quoi c'était c'est
des petites engins des engins de plage à
l'origine c'est rien quoi et dans les
vagues enfin c'était fascinant quand on
s'est fait vraiment plaisir quand vous
arrivez de l'autre côté
vous avez la Route du Rhum qui arrivait
tout le monde est sceptique tout le
monde dit attends c'est pas possible
qu'ils aient traversé l'Atlantique en
handicap tu vois et heureusement il est
Philippe Poupon qui venaient de gagner
la Route du Rhum et qui lui dit ici vous
avez croisé
pour le faire quand même ah oui non mais
c'est des feuilles pour rester dans les
bureaux toute la journée faut pas
totalement clairement pour vouloir
Laurent pour vouloir remonter vers il
faut être un peu son vieux aussi
non enfin la mer c'est fantastique c'est
beau c'est merveilleux mais c'est
vraiment dangereux en plus là on va voir
là tout à l'heure c'est un document un
petit document
il faut connaître un petit peu le métier
après
on a des courses en solitaires mais
c'est pas l'objectif d'être seul sur un
bateau c'est plutôt débile d'être seul
sur le gâteau vivement les courses en
double mixte quand même ça sera beaucoup
plus
agréablement de femmes dans notre métier
qui font parler à tout ça donne pour lui
de partir en mixte avec elle alors vous
êtes un maniaque c'est bien connu vous
êtes vous
êtes un dangereux un dangereux névrote
beaucoup de baleines on lui a souffrir
de vous je tiens à le signaler ici non
vous vous êtes un malade du rationnement
c'est-à-dire que vous avez déjà quand
vous aviez fait votre traversée
120 bouteilles d'eau dans les flotteurs
si vous êtes un maniaque du rangement
par exemple vous arrachez les étiquettes
de vos de vos vêtements il coupe le il
coupe en deux le mange de sa brosse à
dents pour que ça pèse moins lourd
pas
de réchaud il jette à l'eau tout ce qui
pèse du quoi c'est ça mais en fait
l'objectif c'est pas de femme en fait
sache c'est enfin l'objectif c'est
véritablement de préparer le mieux
possible le bateau donc on fait
attention à chaque petit détail
justement pour qu'une fois parti il y a
pas de pas de problème le mange de la
brosse à dents c'est beaucoup quand même
sur un petit catamaran de sport en fait
le moindre kilos est important donc on
essaye de d'être attentif à tous
et alors pour dormir donc comme il n'y a
pas de femme pour pour dormir pour vous
pratiquez l'autohypnose c'est comment
quel rapport
ça peut vous endormir
je ne
donc si je comprends bien après l'amour
tu te mets sur le côté tu te retournes
disons que ça aide à s'endormir de faire
l'amour
c'est les mots bien compliqué pour
expliquer des en fait la gestion du
sommeil on essaye de de réduire les
signes de sommeil dormir à sur commande
à des moments donnés quand la météo nous
le permet ce qui fait que on est le plus
possible à la disposition du bateau pour
faire marcher le bateau alors merci en
tous les cas moi je vous connais mieux
j'espère que nos amis téléspectateurs
aussi alors maintenant on va regarder un
petit un petit sujet filmé où on voit
quand même que c'est pas drôle tous les
jours ce truc la magnétique au Serge
attends
[Musique]
marcher dans le champ de blé
retrouvez pas ça
et du coup
[Musique]
quand vous êtes au début là dans le
petit sujet qu'on a vu au début quand
même vous avez pas l'air d'être très
c'est quand là la situation là ce qui se
passe c'est que c'est les machines très
stressantes donc il y a des moments
quand ces problèmes de la compétition
c'est qu'il faut mener les machines au
maximum de leur limite sans les dépasser
donc il y a énormément de de
temps finalement où on est très stressé
quoi parce qu'on est on est vraiment au
maximum de la vitesse et la machine est
soumise à rue des preuves mais
finalement nous on est là on se demande
si on va pas trop vite si on va pas
casser du matériel parce que une fois le
matériel cassé c'est fini ça va combien
par exemple ces bateaux là ce sont les
bateaux qui vont finalement le plus
rapidement le ce sont les bateaux les
plus rapides à la voile actuellement
ce qui fait à peu près 80 km/h ce qui
est rien en tant que en vitesse pure
mais sur l'eau à la voile c'est très
rapide c'est beaucoup c'est dangereux
alors maintenant on va faire une petite
interview et c'est normal pour un marin
une petite interview attend down
on ne bouge pas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
alors le plus le moins facile ce que
vous préférez dans le bateau
dans le bateau dans la machine dans le
fait de faire du bateau vous préférez
les surf à 25 noeuds sous pleine lune ça
s'est fabuleux
ce que vous détestez dans le bateau ce
que je déteste dans le bateau c'est
justement quand on casse du matériel ça
c'est terrible ça parce que on se
prépare on se prépare toute l'année avec
toute une équipe et tout et quand on
casse du matériel c'est un échec quoi
c'est très dur c'est le coïtu
s'interromptus par exemple le plus grand
pas connu ça toi avant Arnaud avant que
la pilule il y avait le coïti c'est une
terre
alors le plus grand le plus grand le
plus grand moment de votre vie
mais en tout cas des grands moments de
bonheur sur le hobby cat c'était quand
on a traversé l'Atlantique à 20 ans là
et c'est vrai que de dévaler ces vagues
à pleines pleine vitesse c'était
absolument féerique quoi c'était au
niveau de l'adrénaline j'ai rarement
connu aussi fort et le pire moment de
notre vie ça a été par exemple la
rencontre avec un cargo en plein
rencontre de plein face avec un cargo la
nuit comme ça vous dormez puis d'un seul
coup en plus j'étais sur le pont et les
cargos maintenant sont tellement longs
que finalement on n'entend pas
c'est-à-dire que quand on est à l'étrave
du bateau on n'entend pas le moteur et
donc j'ai longer l'ensemble du cargo et
donc c'est un cargo qui était vide et à
la sortie donc j'ai vu les hélices qui
sortaient à moitié de l'eau et
heureusement le mât en fait m'a empêché
de passer sous la sous la voûte du cargo
à l'arrière et de passer ceux dans les
hélices
d'ailleurs il y a une phrase de vous qui
n'entend on peut tous s'inspirer
parfois on croit être à bout et on
arrive à trouver une énergie incroyable
c'est ce qui m'intéresse dans solo dans
la course en solitaire d'ailleurs c'est
pas du tout le fait d'être seul ce qui
est plutôt stupide mais c'est justement
d'aller chercher des forces intérieures
que l'on a chacun d'entre nous mais
qu'on n'utilise pas dans la vie de tous
les jours parce qu'on n'a pas besoin en
fait ce qui vous plaît le plus dans la
vie c'est quoi les gens ils rencontrent
le vibrer
tout ce qui est justement le contraire
l'hypocrisie le chercher du pognon après
les sponsors ça doit être dur ça dans
quoi
c'est pas facile c'est vrai que c'est
pas facile c'est l'inconvénient des
sports mécaniques en fait c'est des
sports coûteux et pour s'exprimer on a
besoin de matériel et donc de
partenaires pour voilà alors que Michel
elle elle a que son talent pour pour
pouvoir s'exprimer
si vous êtes plus sexy en vous Laurent
bourguignon
quand on fait des métiers comme ça des
choses aussi passionnantes avec le temps
de coeur si on ne peut être que
admirer ces gens obligatoires
on peut avoir sa femme au téléphone tous
les soirs
je suis au milieu de l'Atlantique
et nous on est obligé de se faire la
cuisine le ménage
on va en parler donc
mademoiselle Alonzo voilà quelqu'un qui
est prêt à tout faire bon maintenant
alors merci on va rallumer la lumière
mon cerf mon cher Serge caleçon très
bien
et j'accueille quelqu'un que j'adore
parce que ça fait à peu près 12 fois que
je la reçois dans mes émissions ça dort
au début pas trop puis maintenant ça va
beaucoup mieux elle s'appelle Lio
bonjour bonjour
[Applaudissements]
je vous accueille pour une comédie
musicale aux Folies Bergères qui
s'appelle cette fille et cette garçons
alors l'histoire je vais la raconter
vous me direz si je me trompe parce que
les gens pensent que c'est une énorme
partouze qui se passe au foyer et bien
un pointe c'est pas le cas non non c'est
une histoire qui est connue d'ailleurs
qui avait donné lieu à un film un film
hollywoodien donc c'est cette frères qui
vivent
femme et puis il y a les nez qui va à la
ville pour en chercher une il ramène
Émilie qui doit éduquer ses frères un
petit peu rustres un petit peu lourdaux
qui confondent un peu les femmes avec
les vaches laitières faut le dire avec
des bonus avec des bonniches et puis
heureusement il est parti et puis Émilie
ne veut pas être victime de son destin
donc elle essaye de les de les apprendre
à avoir un regard un peu plus tendre sur
elle voilà est-ce que c'est ça
voilà
il devrait en prendre de la graine
est-ce que je propose le magnéto non
magnéto Serge mon chemin mais pour lui
jamais je n'oublierai d'où je viens et
tu seulement comment se rendre tes joues
de notre amour il m'a donné son nom un
homme qui vivrait les jours à venir sans
jamais me mentir
[Musique]
vous déclare unis par les liens sacrés
du mariage
[Musique]
alors vous dites la comédie musicale on
chante parce que les sentiments sont
tellement forts qu'on peut plus parler
c'est une bonne définition de la comédie
musicale je vous oui je tourne parce
qu'il faut mais ça c'est peut-être en
définit quand nous on doit le faire
parce que c'est vrai que on commence par
de la comédie on est dans quelque chose
qui est beaucoup plus proche de nous et
tout d'un coup il faut se lancer ou en
plein milieu d'une phrase à chanter à
pleine voix alors il faut bien trouver
pourquoi et bien parce que c'est
beaucoup plus à chaque fois c'est que on
est tellement elle en peut plus que
chanter un peu plus parler musicale
c'est le sentiment sont tellement forts
qu'on les chante on les chante c'est
assez vrai j'avais jamais moi j'aime
bien cette présentation du féminisme
comme ça ah oui
on va faire une interview maintenant on
va baisser la lumière ah ça y est on ne
bouge pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voilà
c'est ma joie
aussi tiens je vais vous mettre
pas il m'ouvrini
vous avez dit vous allez déclaré c'est
bizarre j'ai toujours été une femme
seule j'étais accompagné finalement très
peu de temps et j'ai eu mes enfants avec
des hommes différents
mais célébrité finalement est un énorme
problème dans ma vie sentimentale est-ce
que vous pensez vraiment que si vous
n'aviez été si vous n'aviez pas été lié
si vous étiez resté Vanda est-ce que
vous auriez moins de problèmes avec les
hommes
oui pourquoi
parce que c'est très difficile de se
retrouver à un moment donné
comme étant monsieur Lio et moi je l'ai
entendu ça des gens qui venaient qui
présentaient mes hommes comme Monsieur
Lio et en fait moi je trouvais c'était
ridicule de la part des autres mais eux
petit à petit trouver ridicule de ma
part d'être Lio mais c'était dommage
parce que je l'étais avant je ne pouvais
pas arrêté tout d'un coup c'était
maintenant c'est comme une seconde
nature Lio et ça a posé des problèmes
oui ça pose des problèmes je vous
propose des problèmes de gagner plus que
son homme aussi alors c'est vrai alors
donc voilà moi j'ai fait le compte quand
même là
on trouve normal par contre de dire
tout le monde s'en fout hein
c'est suffisamment chamaillé sur des
plateaux pour que je puisse vous faire
un compliment sincère je vous trouve
très belle en ce moment là la
présentement j'ai la main si très joli
vous êtes une belle robe vous êtes des
belles nattes et j'adore les brunes et
vous avez du les lèvres un peu rouge ça
ça me plaît ça alors Béatrice je te le
dis tu pouvais mettre le même genre de
rouge à lèvres que lui ça me ferait
plaisir voilà
bon allez maintenant moi je trouve
c'est normal une portugaise ça le fait à
Renaud hein le Portugal
bon alors j'ai compté les hommes
c'est évidemment c'est pas encore Gloria
Lasso mais quand même c'est sur la route
c'est-à-dire il y a eu d'abord votre
premier
Duval ne pas relier qu'on adore tous
les 13 ans et demi
ensuite il y a eu Esteban notre ami
Esteban qui vous avec qui vous avez une
Nubia
ensuite il y a eu Patrick Alexis
avec qui vous avez eu deux enfants Igor
et Smeralda donc là on est déjà un deux
trois non attendez 1
2 3 4 ZAD le dernier en date celui avec
qui vous avez les jumelles voilà
alors vous avez déclaré mon ami Hugo
Pratt m'avait pourtant conseillé de ne
pas tuer le désir dans ce milieu à vide
de cher fraîche personne ne veut d'une
fille avec 5 gosses au basque vous
pensez que ça vous handicap aujourd'hui
tous ces enfants moi ça m'indiquait
pas au contraire dans ma vie de femme
c'est quelque chose de génial mais ça ça
handicap dans mon travail mais oui bien
sûr ça m'handicap dans mon travail parce
que c'est pas de trouver des gens en
général les femmes veulent bien
travailler avec moi mais derrière une
femme réalisatrice il y a toujours un
homme producteur et l'homme producteur
lui n'a pas envie d'une artiste à
problèmes entre guillemets c'est à dire
quelqu'un qui pourrait éventuellement
lui refuser de lui donner la 2 centièmes
heure commentaires gratos puisque c'est
maintenant ce qu'on vous demande moi
depuis que j'ai commencé à tourner mais
cachés ont été divisés par trois voir 4
toujours soit disant pour des problèmes
de cinéma français qui ne marchent pas
mais j'ai toujours vu les les
producteurs avec la même BMW et les
mêmes costumes chez routine donc donc si
vous voulez je trouve que c'est comme un
nouvel esclavagisme parce que comme on
manque de boulot c'est difficile pour
tout le monde donc on commence à dire au
technicien faut diviser vos prix et puis
si c'est pas vous qui êtes d'accord
c'est effectivement et donc il y a autre
chose qui joue c'est quand tout d'un
coup des producteurs ont le choix entre
Lio et une autre et une autre brune pas
trop grosse ils vont prendre peut-être
l'autre brune jolie mais qui a pas 5
enfants et moi je vais être éliminé sur
ce critère immédiatement
oui mais c'est la vérité je vais pas
pourquoi
pour une fille qui a eu cinq enfants
vous êtes vachement bien
pour une fille qui a eu 5 enfants
c'est vrai comment vous faites je baise
c'est parce que tu voulais entendre
Michel vous me connaissez
vous vous disiez donc là vous avez des
problèmes avec votre jus actuel et
pourtant vous disiez je crois que j'ai
trouvé ce que je cherchais je suis une
butineuse il me faut un vrai appel pour
m'arrêter avec lui il y a eu une vraie
osmose comment ça se fait que ce soit
terminé aussi mal après cette vraie
osmose
à me poser qui me pose et c'est des
sacrés problèmes je ne sais pas
non vous aviez l'air d'être tellement en
avoir enfin trouvé je suis très
amoureuse de lui toujours oui mais je ne
veux plus jamais vivre avec lui c'est
différent vous allez vous revoir quand
même
bon vous êtes un peu disputés bon pas là
pour dire ça donc lui il a quand même
pris deux mois ferme
par vengeance je vais quand même un peu
porter plainte sinon on n'a pas pris
deux mois à faire mais j'ai porté
plainte parce que quand on porte plainte
c'est qu'on a pas d'autres solutions
quand on essaie de régler des problèmes
comme on peut avec ses moyens mais que à
un moment donné on va d'échec en échec
et de violence en violence et bien on
s'en refaire à la justice c'est pas que
je trouve ça formidable mais c'est que
je n'avais pas d'autres solutions la
justice représente le père c'est c'est
une autorité à laquelle on s'en remet
quand on reconnaît notre échec notre
échec à nous de résoudre le problème
voilà vous jugiez la sanction un peu
sévère elle est six mois les 6 mois de
prison
je ne suis pas a priori pour la prison
parce que je trouve que c'est pas là
qu'on résout les problèmes mais
les deux mois fermes n'étaient qu'une
partie de la sentence et moi j'avais
besoin de protection et je l'ai obtenu
et
la justice a fait des grands pas pour
les femmes battues il fallait qu'elle
les fasse parce qu'on est vraiment seul
dans ces cas-là et surtout vous êtes
toujours coupable moi la plupart des
hommes qui m'ont parlé depuis n'ont pas
du tout le sentiment de s'adresser à une
victime mais c'est comme les femmes
victimes d'un c'est que je l'ai bien
cherché comment plus tout le monde sait
que j'ai un sale caractère on se dit que
vraiment j'ai du torturer ce pauvre
homme c'est quand même moi qui avait le
nez cassé et le une entorse cervicale et
quatre vertèbres déplacer qu'on a dû
remettre le les Folies Bergères et que
ça a été terrible et que je m'en remets
toujours pas moi en tout cas sur scène
ça se voit pas et sur scène ça se voit
pas mais ça c'est la magie du spectacle
je suis heureuse sur scène alors vous
flippez un peu sur votre trajet jusque
quand on vous voit on a du mal à
comprendre franchement vous dites Lio
c'est pas moi je la mets en scène tous
les jours elle n'existe pas à Lio j'ai
fait un seul coup à Lio j'ai vieilli
mais ça je le disais il y a il y a 10
ans déjà de ça parce que c'est vrai Lio
était la représentation de l'adolescence
elle avait entre 12 et 14 ans quand je
l'ai choisi c'était mon âge à l'époque
dans une BD de Jean-Claude Forest et
elle était le symbole de l'adolescente
oui et c'est vrai que je ne suis plus le
symbole de l'adolescente avec cinq
enfants
c'est au Ghana oui est-ce que est-ce que
vous
je ne critique pas le Gana je tiens à le
dire je veux pas d'histoire je ne
critique pas le Ghana est-ce que vous
avez vous dites j'ai du mal à me voir
vieillir j'ai la mécanique ça faiblice
n'est jamais très agréable oui c'est
vrai et c'est jamais très agréable de
voir les
regards des hommes toujours attirés par
la jeunesse mais moi vous êtes très
attirante vous êtes une femme dans la
plénitude là oui non mais faut pas
flipper
très jeune avec un personnage de Lolita
effectivement Banana Split et tout ça
mais quand on vous voit là
je crois une chose je crois que on se
voit énormément dans le regard que
l'homme que vous aimez porte sur vous et
je crois que quand le regard qu'on
reçoit est quelque chose qui
qui vous affaiblit qui qui vous remet
tellement en question et sur des choses
qui sans doute sont ridicules moi je
trouve que c'est une perte d'énergie
totale mais la vérité et que ça moi ça
me marque il y a des choses qui m'ont
marqué c'est vrai que je me regarde plus
dans la glace avec la même
le même la même des involusures disant
parce que moi je ne me suis jamais
regardé dans la glace avec attention
j'étais désole et je la perds
et c'est une peur qui vient alors je
m'en détourne très vite mais je crois
que je crois que c'est ça tout
simplement je crois qu'on ne vieillit
jamais quand les gens mauvais mais vous
donnent quelque chose
problème c'est que dans la tête on vit
pas vraiment mais le corps vie et puis
après les gens les gens n'y croient pas
quand elle leur dit ça alors vous dites
quand même j'ai hâte d'être une vieille
dame indigne
je vais te passer le cap de l'entre-deux
j'ai jamais aimé avoir le cul entre deux
chaises
c'est vrai qu'on a envie à un moment de
se dire il y a un moment on se dit la
vieillesse il faut que ça serve à ne
plus rien avoir la [ __ ] de rien
au moins cet avantage là c'est ça et de
pouvoir faire plein de conneries et puis
personne n'ose venir vous dire quelle
conne ça c'est génial ça c'est un moment
que j'attends avec la peinture merci Lio
donc on peut nous voir c'est tous les
soirs sauf un soir sauf le lundi soir il
y a des matinées le samedi et le
dimanche bergère en droit que nous
connaissons bien alors maintenant on va
rallumer la lumière
Marc Lavoine l'heure est venue de nous
démontrer vos connaissances musicales
mon cher ami mais tout le monde peut
jouer
[Musique]
voilà alors comme votre chanson
comme c'est les tournesols on a fait un
blind test on a fait
tout le sol
[Musique]
on a fait un blind test avec des
chansons tout le monde peut jouer hein
avec des chansons qui ont des noms de
fleurs ça vous rappelle des souvenirs
liés les blind tests
alors première chanson Didier s'il vous
plaît
[Musique]
un point pour Michel Bernier Natacha
Renault je vous explique aussi alors
vous avez la radio la musique
indispensable vous écoutez quoi un peu
tout un peu tout
le monde peut jouer l'intérêt du blind
test c'est trouver dès les premières
mesures alors deuxième disque
[Musique]
très bien alors maintenant on passe à la
troisième et là je dois dire que vous
avez une avance considérable Michel
Bernier troisième chanson Didier s'il
vous plaît
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
chanson suivante
[Musique]
on ne souffle pas
c'est la rose
allez on le donne
Monsieur Didier
[Musique]
si vous trouvez les deux suivantes
la suivante encore plus dur
ça crée
les gens à connaître hubert-Félix
Thiéfaine
bon et la dernière chanson attention
[Musique]
Serge Lama
fait un plaisir
Michel Bernier mais je suis une
discothèque moi j'adore ça parce que je
regardais toutes les émissions de Guy
luxe parce que mon père me les
interdisait
pas le marais de la chanson des trucs
comme ça le jeu de la chance il disait
de regarder ça évidemment donc
maintenant je vais accueillir Richard
Soviet vous savez pas qui c'est
bonjour
donc Richard on a voulu vous donner la
parole parce que vous avez été victime
samedi dernier lors de la cérémonie des
7 d'or je dirais pas d'une injustice
mais enfin d'un truc qui ressemble pas
trop à la justice donc ce que je vais
dire d'abord c'est que vous êtes
responsable d'une télévision qui
s'appelle télébocase une télévision on
peut dire alternative associatif en tous
les cas qui n'est pas dans
l'établissement de la télévision vous
êtes aussi avec Pierre Karl fils bain
dans la coordination des médias libres
parce que finalement il y a des
fréquences hertziennes qui sont
disponibles et on veut bien les donner à
Lagardère on veut bien les donner à
Bouygues on veut bien donner un Vivendi
mais quand un autre citoyen dit moi je
vais faire ma télé on lui dit non voilà
donc ça c'est pas franchement la
démocratie c'est clair puisque on voit
pas très bien pourquoi à partir du
moment où ces gens-là peuvent racheter
TF1 pour similiars de francs pourquoi
vous vous auriez pas à vous demander à
personne en plus vous aurez pas le droit
de faire une télé voilà alors
il y a une vous avez organisé une
manifestation symbolique au Sept d'Or
devant les Sept d'Or et c'était prévu
pour être sur le toit votre ex pendant
les 7 d'or mais nous on avait aussi
envoyé quelqu'un au sedor c'est Patricia
caillot donc avant de d'en venir à votre
problème on va voir elle alors Patricia
elle est à l'intérieur du Rex vous vous
êtes malheureusement à l'extérieur
malheureusement pour vous et elle était
à l'intérieur du Rex elle était les
distribuée à tous nos amis de la
télévision les losers d'or les losers
d'or ils ont tous été ravis qu'on les
films sauf c'est Julien Courbet et
on ne rit pas quand je dis Julien
Courbet s'il vous plaît lui dit donc
j'ai été filmé samedi soir lors de la
cérémonie des 7 d'or par l'une de vos
journalistes malheureusement il met
impossible d'accepter la diffusion de
ces images
c'est l'humour Julien Courbet alors
maintenant on va regarder le magnéto
c'est cher s'il te plaît
quand même te remettre un trophée
parce que c'est un loser d'or comme tu
as pas tu l'as pas cette
vidéo
justement
je suis ravi franchement et je trouve
qu'il me va bien et est-ce que tu as des
remerciements des remerciements bah les
remerciements c'est à tous ceux qui me
crachent dessus mais voilà regardez vous
avez vu merci
ça va un peu excusez-moi
je suis le chérir et je vais essayer
d'être digne de ce loser d'or et de
looser à chaque fois
merci merci beaucoup Alain merci
on est heureux de vous remettre le
looser dehors
est-ce que vous y attendiez pas du tout
pas du tout mais je suis très ému
toute ma vie je fais ce métier pour
avoir ce truc là toute ma vie j'en ai
rêvé alors maintenant parce que tu peux
plus faire le coup à un autre parce que
je garde un truc là tu as compris que je
garde
donne-moi les autres
Patrick nous sommes
raffole le
loser que
cette d'or pour le
JTS
je suis déjà comblée
c'est le loser
c'est quelque chose
j'ai fait beaucoup d'efforts pour le
mériter pendant 13 ans de suite c'est le
père d'Andor ça il est magnifique mais
c'est moi
remarques
etc c'est moi en plus comment vous avez
fait ça vraiment merveilleuse je peux
toucher vos faux cheveux
merci
c'est vrai que en plus tu es vachement
bien sur la statue
voilà c'était Patricia Galliot à
l'intérieur du Rex samedi dernier pour
distribuer comme dit notre ami Foucault
les perdants d'or c'est joli il parle
bien le français bon
Richard vous êtes là donc vous vous
étiez dehors vous voulez mettre donc
depuis le toit du Rex Michel fils basse
était introduit dans leur ex pour placer
un émetteur sur le toit et là bon il a
été contrôlé par l'un des vigiles qui a
appelé les forces de pour monter sur le
toiture
après c'est moins grave bon donc c'est
vrai donc il a été contrôlé par contrôle
d'identité tout le Saint-Ouen là et
alors vous avez été interpellé vous
un journaliste de Libé était interpellé
un journaliste du Parisien était
interpellé tu réaliste je vous dis quand
vous serez au pouvoir franchement non
mais c'est vrai laisser faire des Théo
alors quand vous avez dit que vous aviez
une carte de presse enfin on a tous les
gens les flic quand je vous le dis c'est
que vous montrez une carte de presse à
un flic qui répond rien à [ __ ] voilà
tout à fait on sait pas la peine d'en
avoir mais j'en ai pas finalement c'est
pareil alors vous avez été vous êtes
convoqué le le 18 novembre au tribunal
pour résistance avec violence c'est
exactement ce qu'a fait votre grand-père
parce que j'ai deux policiers qu'on
portait plein de contre moi bien sûr il
y en avait un de 120 kg un autre de 80
kg ce jour-là j'avais plus de la potion
magique
c'est ce qu'il raconte c'est ce qu'il
raconte en fait alors j'ai beaucoup
témoins évidemment puisqu'il y avait
comme tu le disais il y a un journaliste
de Libération sur les deux Parisiens et
tout le monde s'est fait embarquer tous
les journalistes se sont formés car de
presse ou non avant de regarder le sujet
donc sur l'affaire en question donc
c'est le soir ou la gaffe contre qui
nous n'avons rien a été élu personnalité
de l'année en télévision et je vais
citer Pierre Desproges qui disait la
démocratie c'est la victoire de Belmondo
sur Fellini magnéto dangereux
terroristes en fait qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé alors écoute je sais pas il y a un
gars
[Musique]
on est tous là
on va diffuser on a un appartement qui
est en face du McDo donc juste en face
du Rex 6e étage on va diffuser de la
barre
encore passer ils veulent pas le laisser
passer vraiment c'est délit de sale
gueule
qu'il faut leur soirée là 2000 personnes
niveau casser la toute la population
et bien nous sommes en ce moment
boulevard Bonne-Nouvelle ou une horde de
CS CRS protège donc les gens de la
télévision donc on peut considérer que
les gens de que la télévision a besoin
des CRS pour exister ici des médias
TF1 bloque le quartier nous on utilise
20 mètres carrés voilà
c'est ça la liberté d'expression
quelle impression ça vous fait de
d'assister aux sets d'or justement la
télévision
pareil dans un décor de luxe avec les
mêmes têtes toujours les mêmes qu'on
voit qu'on revoit à partir d'une
manifestation comme ça il faut qu'il ne
contre manifestation mais ce qui est
formidable c'est qu'ils en train de se
faire là tu crois que là ils vont ils
vont réduire le cercle encore ils vont
nous laisser ils vont dans le circuit
autour du camion je crois
que le mec il est plus m'engueuler quoi
alors vous allez recommencer le même mec
qui nous aveugle
c'était pinceau Rex samedi dernier
face-orex qui se trouve qu'en France on
est l'un des derniers pays à ne pas
avoir de télévision associative de libre
accès donc il serait peut-être temps
qu'on y vienne et moi j'ai interpelle
les sénateurs puisque le projet de loi
est en train de faire en train de
naviguer entre le Sénat et le Parlement
et donc on a proposé des amendements et
donc je propose à politique
à chaque fois voilà tant que ça reste un
truc qu'on essaye je suis désolé d'être
gentil d'aller essayer d'appeler les
gens de leur faire des fringues ça
marche pas
reconnue comme une structure
la sympathique j'ai pour vous tant
qu'ils sont pas au pouvoir ils sont
d'accord avec vous le jour où il sort au
pouvoir c'est fini alors mesdames
messieurs je voudrais vous montrer une
cassette en se dépêche on a plus le
temps une cassette encore avec vous
connaissez le film pas vu pas vu pas
pris de Pierre Carl qui était interdit
par Canal+ qui est en vente à partir du
mois de novembre voilà si je voulais
dire qu'on laisse on lance notre chaîne
hertzienne le 16 octobre donc vous
pouvez vous captez téléocal sur le canal
38 canal 38 télévocat sans autorisation
bien sûr puisqu'on l'a pas obtenu du CSA
donc on sera pirate on ira jusqu'à la
saisie
s'il vous plaît faites des trucs bien
très bien alors maintenant maintenant je
demande à Serge caleçon c'est la fin de
l'émission C'est le moment important de
l'émission je demande qu'on baisse la
lumière
on va se
quitter notre ami
Marc Lavoine les tournesols
voilà la pochette du 10 et c'est extrait
de 7e ciel sans septième album
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
fragile au fond de nos voix quand on dit
je t'aime
je crois
freine la fin l'espérance le vrai de
l'enfance qu'on n'oublie parfois
fais-nous une nouvelle pour rendre plus
belle la vie du 100 juin
les lettres jamais reçues
pourquoi
je voulais simplement t'apprendre à
compter sur moi
[Musique]
je voulais simplement t'apprenne à
compter avec moi
sur le bout de nos doigts
[Applaudissements]
marcher dans le champ de blé
retrouve les parasols
les chevaux qui caractérisent
les souvenirs étaient mêlés
le coup de la liberté
oh mince la chance qui nous reste
quand même
mais votre communion d'elle la petite
hirondelle que liberté
[Musique]
de sentir encore quelque chose de chaud
minuscule nous résistance
qui fait quand même bouger les choses
marcher nos champs
[Musique]
les jours qui caractéris
tes parents ont mal tourné
[Musique]
et il passe-t-il maintenant
[Applaudissements]
de la liberté
courir dans les tournesols
retrouvez les parasols
les chevaux qui caracolent
les souvenirs
il est parti demain
[Musique]
le niveau de la liberté
le nom de la liberté
le nouveau de la liberté
[Musique]
bravo merci
Marc Lavoine les tournesols
très bonne chanson très très bonne
chanson il a fait la musique avec kARIO
bravo Margot asseoir merci beaucoup bah
voilà comment on dit la
passe une bonne soirée vous marrez moi
je l'ai vu je vous garantie c'est super
dans des moments de midi on tourne dans
toute la France Laurent Bourgnon donc le
17 octobre sur le bateau alors moi je me
suis jamais intéressé aux courses de
voilier et tout ça là maintenant je vous
connais je vais regarder je vais
regarder toute la journée savoir où si
vous êtes premier ou deuxième d'accord
mais on va s'appliquer pour faire tout
soutenir Laurent Bourgnon Lio donc
Folies Bergère cette garçons et cette
fille comédie musicale une vraie comédie
musicale Renault Muselier si vous
interpellaire votez pour lui ouais si
vous êtes prêts
bocal c'est quand c'est sur le canal 38
le 16 octobre canal 38 le 16 octobre est
maintenant apportez-moi voilà linda
Hardy 25 ans demain ma chérie
merci
c'était tout le monde en parle prochaine
émission la semaine prochaine
merci et à samedi
si vous voulez bien Ciao
[Musique]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
inarritube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu